Speaker 1: It is finally happening. We are
going to get six years worth of Donald Trump's
tax returns after spending so much time and
so much money and so much effort. Exhausting
every possible means. The House Ways and Means
Committee has the tax returns and they have voted
that indeed they are going to release them. This
is absolutely huge and we will talk about what we
might find in these tax returns. We already found
out the supposed audits that were taking place
were not actually taking place. Will delve into
that in a moment. Reuters reporting U.S. House
Committee to release Redacted Trump Tax Fight Tax
Filings. The US House of Representatives committee
voted yesterday to release partially redacted tax
filings from Trump and said tax authorities had
failed to properly scrutinize his returns while
he was in office. Despite endless, breathless,
apoplectic claims that the IRS is working in a
politically partizan way to target Republicans,
Trump's filings were not even actually
scrutinized in the way he claimed that
they were. The committee said the U.S. Internal
Revenue Service did not follow its own rules
when it failed to audit Trump's tax returns
during three of his four years in office.
Members said Congress should pass a law to
strengthen the presidential audit program.
Let's look at a video here of Congressman
Lloyd Doggett explaining what we are going
to get and when we are going to get it.
Speaker 2: That's going to be it. We're
not also going to get all the tax
returns. Just to be very clear.
Speaker 3: Here, you will get all of the tax
returns that the Supreme Court and the lower
courts said that Mr. Neal's request could get. You
will get all of those that may be delayed for a
few days, only to vomit fruit for time to redact
things like Social Security numbers, personal
I.D. numbers, that type of thing. But you will get
the complete Trump tax returns, such as they are
for the years that Mr. Neal requested.
Speaker 2: Okay, so that's 20, 2015 to 2020,
just to be clear. Yes, that's.
Speaker 3: Correct. And I think
what I find surprising our focus had been on
the IRS audit and whether it was being done
properly. Right. The IRS did no audits at all.
Well, such time as the day they received Mr.
Neal's request for these documents, and that
day they requested the first audit. They have
yet to complete a single audit of Mr. Trump.
Speaker 1: Can you imagine? And we're going to
delve more into the audit part. But the critical
question is, at this point in time, what might we
learn from these tax returns? Amend a number of
different things. Trump is not as wealthy as he
claims to be, almost certainly. And in fact, we
have so many other sources that suggest that is
the case. We may learn about Trump's conflicts of
interest. Trump's tax returns could potentially
reveal conflicts between his business dealings
and his role as president of the United States,
potentially conflicts of interests with a
national security consequence and it could
include details about financial arrangements
with foreign governments are individuals or
questionable relationships. We could learn about
tax evasion or outright fraud. There have been
concerns for a long time about Trump's financial
dealings, including whether and it seems almost
guaranteed that he is, from everything
else we know, whether he is misstating,
exaggerating or understating the value of certain
assets for whatever purpose is convenient at the
time. Use of charitable funds. Trump has been
criticized for his use of funds from charitable
found from the charitable foundation, which
remember had its own legal problems some years
ago, including that he was using that money as
a sort of personal expense slush fund in the
tax returns. It's possible that we might learn
more about that. Hidden assets, whether Trump
has hidden assets or income streams that have
not been previously disclosed and there is much
more. Why would Trump work so hard to prevent
the release of the tax returns? Well, based on
the reasons I just gave you, there could be legal
concerns. In other words, if indeed Trump's tax
returns contain information about possible fraud
or any of the other things I mentioned that could
potentially be used against Trump in a legal
context, it could be the evidence for the tax
evasion or fraud that he is expected suspected of
engaging in. And that could be why he didn't want
the tax returns released. Image Protection. Trump
is extraordinarily vain and narcissistic. The tax
returns, as I mentioned, might. Revealed Trump's
not as wealthy as he claims to be or that he has
debts that are maybe bad for his image. So image
protection. And thirdly, to some degree, strategic
considerations in the sense that if he had normal
followers, they might react to the information
contained in the tax returns negatively and
might abandon Trump. Trump doesn't have normal
followers. We experienced that during 2016, and
the phrase I could shoot someone on Fifth Avenue
and not lose any support, it actually seems much
more accurate than we might have assumed at the
beginning. So in theory, there would be strategic
considerations for Trump wanting to prevent the
release of his tax returns. In practice, it's
not clear his followers really give to whatevers
about what the guy has done or claimed or lied
about, or whatever the case may be. So we are
days away, maybe even less, from the release of
six years of Trump's tax returns. We will delve
into it. But one thing we know, the IRS audit
claims were lies. I want to talk about that next.